foreign
hello
what's goody what's goody
hello right Tenors
hello
how goes it out there y'all
okay let me bring that up a little bit
hello
what's good
welcome to the right tent Club everyone
we are about to write a joke
live together
we already got peeps pulling up
I see it's Akuma says good morning
[Music]
very nice
and they said I missed yesterday's
episodes so I made sure to be up bright
and early
oh
wow all right wow thank you so much it's
Akuma that means the world thank you
the homie Dario says good morning all
good morning homie Dario
Joan Fuchs been saying hi all my sister
knees are both loving it oh talking
about Wednesday Bobby said good morning
I hope
you're having a blessed day so far
indeed indeed
I've actually been up since
six
this morning actually woke up and was
awake so we just got up
um
yes indeed though yeah Wednesday is good
my wife and I are watching Wednesday
that is a good show it's so funny I was
just watching an interview with um the
CEO of Netflix
uh re-hastings
and New York Times did a great
series they interviewed a bunch of
different CEOs and stuff uh that like
just came out and was really interesting
but he was talking about why he was just
watching Wednesday but he was also
talking about
they were comparing like Amazon and
Netflix and all these streamers and
stuff because I'm about to
um release a new video
about how Andrew Schultz
has killed Netflix
oh
I know
it's very exciting I'm loving doing
these videos if you didn't see the one I
just did on the richest comedian
definitely check that one out
uh it's on my personal YouTube channel
Joe buyers so definitely go check that
out
uh we cooking up some special things
over there
but
um it was funny the CEO of Netflix was
talking about
this new show Wednesday apparently
they're the original content game which
Netflix won was just volume just getting
as much content as possible
but now the new
I guess content game 2.0 is now quality
and everyone is
trying to produce the highest quality
content possible now the volume is out
there now the next differentiator is
common quality which is very interesting
and good timing as that's what I'm doing
on um kind of doing on my personal
YouTube channel it's like hot breath we
have a lot of quantity and quality
you can see on my personal YouTube
channel it's less content but higher
quality production uh content which is
very exciting
but
Reed Hastings said which was very
interesting that
talking about the different streaming
platforms and stuff it's like
the funny thing about Wednesday being on
Netflix is it was actually produced by
MGM which is owned by Amazon and Netflix
uses Amazon web services uh to host like
their overall Amazon web services
like I think like the CIA uses all sorts
of weird stuff I hope I didn't just get
demonetized for using that phrase but
um it was just really interesting to see
um
yeah it's interesting to learn about
what's happening in the content game and
how it can help comedians it's very
interesting
Annabelle hello what goody Annabelle
says hi
hello oh Scott Shannon watching from
Italy but I have to go get my daughter
from school I'll probably miss the most
important part
hey thanks for popping in all the way
from Italy
how cool well no worries you can always
hang out for the replay later fam
but we are about to jump
into our live riding exercise
odino is in the building he said Neil
Brennan discusses in his new special on
Netflix VP VIP dinner he attended I need
to watch that still I heard him talking
about how he had a deep fake
part of his special he like a few
minutes of it were actually a deep fake
um which I want to go back and check out
yeah I haven't watched I don't really
haven't been watching that many specials
but we got Aaron despiva in here what's
goody fam
hilarious Bobby said she's been called
Wednesday her entire life that's perfect
but my birthday's not Friday the 13th
it's on Halloween oh
they're fancy I love it
Bobby benavidez in the building very
nice very nice so yes
we're about to write a joke live oh my
gosh this is so exciting so as you all
are here and I'm greatly appreciated
um
Jerry Crow was goody
Robert Brown what's goody let's hit
These Bars
goody well let's do it now that Robert
mentions it let's do that my friend
so
we are about to write a joke live on the
air which is so exciting if you have
been watching my YouTube videos just
real quick
I have a fiddly fig that is slowly dying
so like each video you can see it's
starting to wither away I don't know
what's happening with it
it has brown spots all over it
I've
checked
I don't know it could be root rot I
don't know I feel terrible though I did
buy it on sale but
I feel terrible that it's dying
but I don't know what to do about it
Bobby said was goody distracted by work
but trying to pay attention
Bobby said read his joke now
so he can hear it all right
Bobby benavidez
I never understood how a milkshake could
bring all the boys to the yard I mean it
seems like it would melt and spoil
pretty quickly sitting outside
all right I like it yeah yeah yeah
maybe not bring the boys to the yard
maybe bring
boys to lactose intolerance I don't know
I don't know
oh
I think she meant the guy from Italy oh
well all I saw was he
I don't see Scots though
I do not see Scott hasn't posted a joke
the guy from Italy
um
BS Mr Williams you are right on time
what's the live joke topic today
we are getting into that now my friend
he said we just start I'm lost my life
is over this is the pathway to
enlightenment
hilarious
hilarious what's up Brandon Carr thanks
for posting a joke fam well that's what
we're about to get into my friends we
are about to write a joke live on the
air
so officially now that we are in here at
20 people deep
officially welcome
to the right tank
the word of the day is
all right all right all right
here we go fam
nice ready to go says Mr Williams very
nice
Bobby said I have too much nitrogen in
the soil
for my fiddle leaf fig
ah
I don't know I hate that I don't know
how to mitigate that
um I would like it to bounce back I just
don't know
but in the meantime in between time my
friends
I wonder if I should add a thing
like a text thing saying
the word of the day let me try that
really quick
Shake today is word of the day is Shake
um and then scroll
there we go is that too too big
all right welcome to the 80d club
there we go
all right good morning Morris welcome
just in time Tim Craft as well good to
see you buddy
yes postal jokes here the word of the
day is Shake
and that it's Akuma like that intro yeah
yeah yeah that was made
by a hot Brethren Patrick Fowler
he made that
uh during the pandemic when we started
this bad boy
and now we are starting today's writing
contest I know I appreciate you all for
hanging out in your patience in a way we
go
so I do Post these as a separate YouTube
video so um
you may hear
some redundancies or something but
that's just for the video
foreign
so here we go
all right welcome back to the right 10
Club your weekly joke writing challenge
where you get 10 minutes to write a new
joke using a new word today's word of
the day as you see
here is
Shake
so we're gonna be writing a joke live on
the air together using the word Shake
and today
we are using
a uniball 207 plus I had a lovely
corporate gig this past weekend and I
always like to treat myself got got some
new notebooks and a new set of pins and
there's uniball 207 plus
it's a good it's a good strong pin
I always love uniball is a dope brand I
do love using them
um
this one came in black blue and red I
got a three pack for you
yes
but you're here to write a joke not to
learn about pins
um which I could talk about all day so
all that being said
the word of the day is Shake today's
date is
[Music]
boy this is great for retention
uh today's date is the 14th 12 14 22.
I'm gonna I'm gonna restart that that's
hilarious
all right welcome back to the right 10
Club my friends this is your weekly joke
writing challenge where you get a new
word and write a new joke in 10 minutes
today's word of the day you see
scrolling across the screen it is Shake
so we're gonna shake things up a bit
by using our uniball 207 plus I had a
corporate gig this weekend and treated
myself to some new pins and uh uniball
it's uh always a good smooth right
so the word of the day is Shake
and I like to use different color ink
too just to shake it up a bit
all right
so we have 10 minutes on the clock where
the day is Shake
feel free to ride along with me feel
free to if you're watching on our
Wednesday live stream when we do this
feel free to uh spit out ideas as I'm
spitting them out and um
let's get into it my friends so 10
minutes word of the day Shake
so to shake things out
first thing I like to do is just get the
ideas out there shake things out not
doing anything right or wrong or good or
bad or funny or not it's just getting
the juices flowing by just what do you
think of when you hear the word shake
what comes to mind
off the jump shake and bake
which is um Talladega Nights
which from that movie Talladega Nights
and look there's no
wrong way to do this this is literally
for the next few minutes just getting as
much out of our head as possible and
then we can start to go back
and formulae it into a joke
um
Shake Your Booty I believe that is a
song right
shake shake shake shake shake shake your
booty
um
uh
pepper shaker you know just getting the
ideas out here pepper shaker
uh James Bond shaken not
stirred
and that's James Bond
there's a common phrase
um
was it don't
Shake
a baby
Shake could be connected to
um
Parkinson's
I think Shake It Off is a song right
is that a t Swift song
uh Shake oh of course
milkshake
milkshake and that makes me think of
like um lactose intolerance
and there could be some fun uh
word play around
um
shaking off the sugar giving you the
sugar shakes perhaps
um Steak and Shake is one
but see this is why we do the
brainstorming part at the beginning
because it kind of just
it's low pressure you're not trying to
do anything but just word vomiting it
makes the joke riding process very
accessible because you can see in just a
little bit we've already done we've gone
from like movie quotes to uh like food
and to like dancing so and common
phrases and stuff so whatever comes to
mind you know
words phrases
uh tangential connections Shake makes
you think of bake which makes you think
of cooking I don't know
um
oh nice yeah yeah Augie said Shake
Weights yes indeedy my friends
um
excuse me one second we seem to have
some spam in the live chat
so shake weight is funny though and it
could be
Shake Weight
um
could be no I want to lose weight
so it could be something with um
shake weight because or they should call
it shake fat because that's all you do
as you're shaking it you know
uh Shake It Off Shake It Out
shake and bake shake so I just like to
brainstorm the first half
um just to kind of get the juices
flowing and then the second half we like
to kind of start to organize it into
a noise toit
joke
all right so next let's let's get into
it here so milkshake
um I don't know there's something about
milkshake that I like so let me try to
play around with that because I think
there's maybe like a lactose
intolerance joke
um
here so now we want to start formulating
into a joke so
way to do that is you first start off
with your premise so what do you want to
say in this joke so I would like to say
that I love
milkshakes
in the setup but so then in a one-liner
it's a misdirect you're setting up the
auto stick in One Direction and then the
punch line says a second Direction
oh earthquakes is a good one it's Akuma
so I want the punchline to actually say
I hate milkshakes
so you see we're working on creating
that misdirect so your setup should say
one thing but the punchline says the
opposite so for I love milkshakes
what are all the ways we could say I
love milkshakes
my favorite food
is milkshake
is milk our milkshakes
um
milkshakes are my
favorite
cheat meal
I could
live on
milkshakes
maybe I just
started
a milkshake
diet
and maybe there's something with like a
juice cleanse
and maybe there's a joke I mean it's
kind of dirty I mean it's a poop it's a
poop joke it's a poop joke
something about
diarrhea
um
milkshake one of the basic food groups
yeah yeah
I'll see you there Tim
food pyramid yeah so maybe there is a
Mystic we can do around
um
yeah it being healthy but nah type deal
you know so I just started a milkshake
diet a juice cleanse
maybe there's a word that rhymes with
juice
or cleanse colon cleanse
I just started a milkshake diet
so just to get the juices flowing my
doctor
recommended
a colon cleanse
milkshake brings all the boys to the
yard
and makes them sit on the toilet brings
all the boys to the yard but if you're
over 30
that yard is an outhouse
a doctor recommended a colon cleanse
milkshake so we're getting we're getting
somewhere here we got about
90 seconds left see if we can get
something here at the buzzer I'd have to
recommend it a colon cleanse milkshake
um
prescribed
what is it called
uh laxative
um
so maybe a milkshake is cheaper than a
laxative
or as I call it a laxative
I just started a new milkshake diet
laxative
milkshakes
30 seconds milk Dairy Queen has the best
I feel like I did a similar joke to this
with a different word but maybe
something around like
Dairy Queen
has the best milkshakes serves Royal
milkshakes
I know why the best milkshakes are at
Dairy Queen all right
so at the buzzer here
Dairy Queen
serves Royal milkshakes right after I'm
on the throne
so it's basically trying to say that
they're delicious but they leave me on
the toilet you know
I feel like there was maybe a joke
get a word of the day a few weeks ago
where I had a royal Throne joke so I
don't know what that says about me but
writing a joke in in 10 minutes live on
the internet at 10 A.M
you're welcome for even doing this for
free so
to kind of land the plane here
um
all right
I now
how
Dairy Queen got
its name
their milk shakes
to me on the throne
on the porcelain throne
so
not great
not something I'm gonna do on stage
anytime soon but
the whole name of this game is to sit
down and write for 10 minutes to focus
on just nothing but silly Joe crying for
10 minutes
and if you've watched this before you
know the name of the game is repetition
so you write 20 jokes and end up keeping
one so
hopefully this at least got your juices
flowing and you can use this as a
jumping off point to spark some riding
momentum that you can then take into
your day
after this keep writing you know this is
just a little brainstorming exercise
that I hope helped you out there and if
it did subscribe and tell your fellow
comedy writers to um hang out with us
here at the hot breath diverse on our
podcast we release every Monday on our
Tuesday live streams or our Wednesday
live streams it's all about Comics
helping Comics here
so we'll see you next week y'all
bye
all right
so I don't hate it
I don't love it
but
for 10 minutes
it's good enough it's good enough
so that being said
post your jokes in the live chat and I
will read it live on the air
and I am going to post my joke in the
voting poll because in our Facebook
group
we do
a live uh voting
people will vote for their favorite uh
jokes
live in our Facebook group
and uh sorry there is no Guinness today
he was in my wife's office and she was
in a meeting so
you know
it do what it do fam
but I'm glad y'all still hung out even
though Guinness isn't here
so what did I say
I now know how Dairy Queen got its name
I swear I did a similar joke for another
well we did but
it is what it is you know in 10 minutes
it do what it do fam it do what it do
oh Michelle said it was rough but we
made it
Denise with the Applause yes
Bob Kirk in here
very nice
all right so I'm seeing some jokes
coming in here
um
nice so I'm going to read your jokes
live on the air my friends oh homie
Dario said nice one Robert very nice I
love the love
it comes through this community oh
yay
[Music]
so shall we get into your jokes my
friends
shall we read your jokes live on the air
first
joke
I'm reading here
Steve poger good to see you fam
you said I balanced that love with light
roasting
[Music]
um so let's see the first joke my
friends and thank y'all for hanging out
we are 30 strong right now on this
weekly joke writing community so thank
you all for hanging out I'm gonna read
your jokes live on the air now
and I will go to here
there you go
so now you know
uh the word of the day is
Shake
so feel free to post your jokes in the
live chat
using the word shake that I will uh read
live on the air
and the first one I'm seeing my friends
ish
Aaron despiva is what it's looking like
so
Aaron to spiva's joke I was shaken as a
child more like shocked Every Time I
grabbed the electric fence
all right
I see you there fam
very fun so like a very um that is
shocking
like a very exhilarating
electrifying childhood
[Music]
all right next joke
Bobby benavidez
already read his but we'll read it again
I never understood how a milkshake could
bring all the boys to the yard I mean it
seems like it would melt and spoil
pretty quickly sitting outside yes
agreed
My milkshake brings all the boys to the
yarn
if y'all didn't know that's a song
My milkshake brings all the boys to the
yard it it I won't even call it a song
it's an Anthem
definitely worth checking out
um
next joke Joan
Joan
uh Shake Rattle and Roll is my favorite
song it's the only time in my life that
I've ever been athletic
all right nice
congrats Joan
for dating yourself
shake a lot of songs with shaking it I
guess very fun
um looks like I'm next we have Brandon
this is a branding car good to see you
fam
I trained my dog how to shake I say vet
and he starts shaking
nice
very funny I like that taught him how to
shake and the command is vet because
he's shaking because he's scared nice
well done there Brandon nice and silly
um
whose joke is this Tim Craft
my dog I tell him shake and he brings me
a malt
stupid dog
ah
malt
like another word for shake you're
saying physically Shake but it's like a
dessert Shake I like it people are
definitely gonna empathize with your dog
though and turn like if you're on stage
and you say stupid dog people are gonna
take the dog's side
um but for this 10 minute riding
exercise you know you use the word shake
so
can't uh can't fault you there
hilarious Jones said I have no words for
that remark Joel I'm shaking too much
well I didn't mean to offend you Joan
it's just it's all fun and games right
right
[Music]
all right
yeah
Jerry Kroll my wife says the worst
feeling she has every day is leaving the
house for work as thoughtful as a
thoughtful husband I removed that now
her worst feeling is when I shake her
awake at 4 30 A.M
my wife says the worst feeling she has
every day is leaving the house for work
as a thoughtful husband I remove that
now her worst feeling is when I shake
her awake at 4 30 a.m nice
that's a fun one there Jerry
I see you I see you Jerry I like that
leaving the house for work
now her worst feelings when I shake her
awake at 4 30. nice nice use of shake
there Jerry nicely done
next up we have Maurice
Morris
a few years ago my Jewish cousins
converted to Islam and became an Imam
we had no idea he had been really
looking to shake shake things up Ah
that's a word play
[Music]
I hope I pronounced all that right
but yes I see the word play there
Dino during covid a handshake on a date
counted
as getting to Third Base
yeah
all right hand shake I didn't even think
of that phrase nicely done there dino
very creative
oh hilarious it's Akuma said shake from
Aqua Teen Hunger Force very funny
uh Bobby Sutton
people have always said about me there's
something wrong with that girl I can't
take all the credit Mom liked her baby
shaking
not stirred
oh my heavens
oh my heavenly day
shaken not stirred yeah I was
put on a few there you did the James
Bond and like the shaken babies phrases
very nice
well done there Bobby I like that that's
a that's a twofer there
Bob
Sugar Shack is where all the shaking
takes place till I fill my sweet tooth
my cavities are deep
mmm deep cavities for deep vittles mmm
Sugar Shack all the shaking maybe some
with like sugar shakes in there
I like it though
so delicious
mmm and the holidays are coming up which
is um
sugarlicious mmm
all the cookies cookies and cake oh
next joke oh and I just saw Bobby's
comment
brown spots too much nitrogen replace
half the soil and mix old and new soil
well
goodness I have high quality planting
soil or potting soil that's supposed to
be the the good stuff right ain't that
the loud pack
ain't that that dank ain't that that
pressure
thought we were pushing p on these
plants
with that loud pack that's strong
that guy that gas that Gaga the sticky
icky
I used high quality potting soil
you're saying
remove half the soil and then replace it
with more new potting soil
how does all that nitrogen get in there
next joke
I have so many questions
so whose joke is this my hubby
Michelle Van Dusen
my ho my hubby got shakes for his
birthday thankfully he didn't share
because the flu
sucks
all right I'll see you there I'll see
you there Michelle
nicely done
shakes thought it was milkshakes but
it's actually the sick shakes I like the
misdirect there
uh Robert Brown
Robert Brown I rescued a dog from a bad
home it's weird having a dog from a
previous owner sure my dog knows how to
sit and stay but when I say shake down
my dog grabs a knife and takes away
I meant the laughing sound effect
[Music]
very funny Shakedown grabs a knife and
takes my wallet that's just good that's
just good clean fun there that's good
silly goosery
well done there Robert
next joke up
we have a Mike Marr when you shake my
family tree you just get nuts
very funny
nicely done there Mike I like that's
just a nice quick joke
the homidario I was at a wedding and the
DJ played shake what your mama gave you
but I wasn't sure how to twerk my Deep
Sea Catholic guilt
I guess it worked because I was shook
for the rest of the night
oh that's hilarious didn't know how to
I wasn't sure how to twerk my deep soda
seated Catholic guilt that's funny
that's very funny nicely done there
homie Dario
uh Sunday Sandy Bernstein I miss shaking
hands so I started volunteering at the
Parkinson's Foundation
[Music]
silly Mister right there I like it
shaking hands we're assuming it's
physically shaking hands but it's the
other Parkinson's shaking hands I like
my sister right there Sandy
Bob grunfest
new member
let's go
Owen is Raj Singh yes I'm reading your
jokes in the live chat the word of the
day is shake so post your jokes
using the word Shake
and I'll read it live on the air just be
sure to put the word joke in front of it
like Mr Williams did with his joke
um but back to the list we're going in
chronological order there
well we had Bob grunfest welcome to the
club fam
um
where'd it go
oh there we go
trimmers make my hands shake so much
that when I pass people on the street
they start singing choral music
oh like it's a dance move
okay Shake Rattle and Roll I see you
there Bob well done buddy
welcome to the club
uh Olga since quarantine nobody shakes
hands anymore only people with
Parkinson's disease
oh a lot of
a lot of Parkinson's jokes on this uh a
lot of people went dark I see
this was this is Robert Brown said
reposted from
oh we already read that one nice
the dog grabs a knife and shakes you
down yeah that's hilarious
Victoria oh no this isn't the one with
the um
here we go this is the one using the
word my friend said she gained weight
from The Slim Fast shakes she drank I
said those are not slim fast they were
weight gain shakes at the daughter
nice
I wonder at weight gain shakes Slim Fast
shakes that's funny
maybe fat fast
Shake
and then maybe like a cherry on top or
with whipped cream or something
[Music]
um
delicioso
mmm sugar
um
hope Bobby shared the link about my fig
tree thank you
with the brown spots
just water it more I've tried to water
it more and I've tried to not water it
more and I've tried to underwater it and
I've tried to move it into a different
room with more sun
um
I don't know but it is definitely
struggling
yeah thanks for sharing uh Robert's joke
um Victoria I mean not Victoria you're
welcome Victoria and thanks for sharing
Robert's joke there Bobby
uh next joke
oh nope
we read this one
who's is this
I've been so exhausted I haven't slept
since Whoopi Goldberg and Elton John
left Twitter
all right all right
noise thanks for sharing I'm not sure
whose joke that is I can't find it in
the Facebook group
um
Mike Rowe
uh I got arrested while picking my son
up at school probably should have left
the shake weight at home
oh my you dog you
you dog you
Shake Weight good use of the word Shake
there fam
um micro
we just read micros
it's Akuma
I went on first date with the woman of
my dream she said her life had been
trauma free and she's highly motivated
it didn't last long
I guess I like my women shaking and not
stirred
ah so maybe
if it didn't last long maybe you did
something if you could imply that you
did something
to um shake her and make her want to
leave type deal that you scared her or
something
out there on them dating streets
oh thank you Bobby Bobby diving deep on
the fiddly Fig research but I mean the
nitrogen could be a thing too
you know
um next joke I'm seeing here
Leroy
uh my wife my ex-wife asked me how I
could go out for
how I could go out for a hamburger when
I had steak at home I told her I went to
Steak and Shake where I don't get nagged
as much
nice ex-wife I could I see why ex-wife
hilarious
uh next joke
I'm seeing
Mr Williams
uh I didn't like church or religion too
much but I went to church and the pastor
told me he would shake off my demons and
wow now I'm single
nice misdirect the demon being your ex
my sister right there Mr Williams
um Tracy J
bought a shake weight to help with
weight loss but it just made me strong
enough to carry more groceries and just
toned enough to look like Johnny Bravo
now I got to shake these infomercials
all right all right I like that shake
weight Shake The infomercials nice word
play there Tracy J
uggie I go to the gym to lose some
weight so I use some Shake Weights and
let me tell you the only thing I lost
was this guy's phone number I guess
phone number I guess wanted me to use
his Shake Weight
oh my Heavens glad you got out of there
Augie
um
let me go to the YouTube channel
as it appears uh
isra
is Raj Singh looks like your joke got
flagged it says my dog shakes his booty
yesterday my dog ran off
and in the evening I saw he in a party
with my girlfriend dancing I'm happy for
my dog now he can learn more positions
than doggy style from my girlfriend
oh my heavens
shakes
his booty
though yeah I use the word Shake there
I see why YouTube flagged it
um
Steve poger
relationships are like a Shakedown but
the mafia isn't cruel enough to make you
pick apples on the weekend
ha
ha ha ha ha ha
oh Shakedown Mafia I'll yeah
very well done there
very well done I like that one Steve
very silly
well nice job everyone Scott Shanahan
is this our gentleman from Italy
he said
uh I met a girl at Steak and Shake the
only thing I got from that relationship
was diarrhea
Love at First wipe
[Music]
thank you thank you yes that was worth
the whole live stream getting that
little joke out there
hilarious
nice
saw Walton said I got a tattoo on my
pelvis it reads shake well before
enjoying oh
all right
so as we were Landing This Plane here my
friends we do this every
single Wednesday at 10 A.M every Tuesday
at 5 p.m I'm also on here doing a joke
feedback hour where you bring jokes
you've written out outside of this live
writing Club
and uh I'm live with my buddy Yoshi and
we give you joke feedback
on those jokes
so uh with that being said we do live
voting in our Facebook group so who
is in the lead on our Facebook group at
the moment
let's see who is in the lead over there
who is in the lead over there
and Robert said another great round I
agree Robert I definitely agree
and hey while you're on YouTube
if you haven't watched my new video
if you haven't subscribed who here is
not subscribed to my YouTube channel my
personal YouTube channel
where are you
show yourselves
well we can fix that right now
I just linked it in the live chat go
subscribe to my new YouTube channel I'm
doing a lot of cool videos over there
that that you'll really enjoy if you
love this channel
and uh oh
it looks like Bobby Sutton
is today's winner my friends
oh Scott said
uh just learned you have another Channel
today
all right well welcome aboard yes go
subscribe there and check out some of
the dope videos I have going on
um they're more like video essay Styles
I just did a video about the world's
richest comic
just did a video about Dane Cook just
did a video about Bert Kreischer
Kevin Hart don't do a lot of cool videos
over there
and Robert said bro who would be so
Shameless to not watch And subscribe
to watch and not subscribe amen
Jordan Lehman said subbed
yeehaw
K Victoria likes the videos thank you
Denise liked the Dane Cook video oh
thank you
so
that being said Bobby
congratulations Bobby Sutton has won
today's joke of the day and very well
deserved
very very well deserved and she said
thank you hot breath Community for your
sick sense of humor hilarious
and her joke was you know people have
always said about me there's something
wrong with that girl I can't take all
the credit Mom liked her baby shaking
not stirred
so yes indeed that is um
a dark joke but that's how the hot
breath of Earth gets down here
but well deserved
Bobby is the one who posts our jokes in
our Facebook group every
single day
and she does so much more to help the
hot breath diverse continue to grow so
we are eternally grateful for that Bobby
thank you
and Bobby is also the one responsible
for our ending
y'all
she's the reason why we end all of our
live streams that way so um
congratulations Bobby and other people
in the comments are saying
congratulations I love it
great joke though shaking on Stern and
it's personal well done
let's land This Plane my friends I hope
you have a lovely
happy Wednesday out there I'm always so
grateful you spend your Wednesday
mornings or afternoons or evenings
wherever you are around the world I
appreciate you hanging out with us
and you all have a good day
and of course
Angel's on y'all Angel's on y'all we
will see y'all next week
have a good day everyone
bye